You Start Your path and you think that
you're heading towards your star and so
you go in that direction and
then because you're here,
the world looks a particular way,
but then when you move here,
the world looks different and you're
different as a consequence of having made
that voyage and so what that means is
that now that thing that glimmers in front
of you is going to have shifted its
location because you weren't very good at
specifying it to begin with and now
that you're a little sharper and more
focused than you were,
it's going to reveal itself
with more accuracy to you.
And so then you have to take a.
You know,
it's almost like 180 degree reversal.
But it isn't because you know you've.
I mean you've gone this far and
that's a long ways to get that far,
but that's a lot farther than you would
be if you just stayed where you were
waiting.
And so it doesn't matter that
you overshoot continually.
Because as you overshoot,
even if you don't learn
what you should have done,
you're going to continually learn
what you shouldn't keep doing.
And if you learn enough about
what you shouldn't keep doing,
then that's tantamount at some point
to learning at the same time what you
should be doing.
So it's okay.
So it's like this.
Now what's cool about it though,
I think is that as you progress,
the degree of overshooting
starts to decline,
right?
And that we know that there was
nothing hypothetical about that.
As you learn a new skill,
like even to play it,
play a song on the piano,
for example,
you overshoot madly,
you make an all sorts of
mistakes to begin with.
And then the mistakes
they disappear.
There's a great ted talk,
I think it was about sky,
uh,
set up a really advanced computational
recording system in his home and recorded
every single utterance his young
child made while learning to speak.
And then he put together the child's
attempts to say certain phonemes and put
them in the list and you can hear the
child deviating madly to begin with.
And then after hundreds and
hundreds of repetitions,
just zeroing in on the exact phoneme.
So you know,
you might not know this,
but when kids babble,
because they start babbling
when they're quite young,
they babble every human phoneme including
all sorts of phonemes that adults
can't say,
and then they they die into their
language so that after they learn,
say English,
then there's all sorts of phonemes
they can no longer here or pronounced,
but to begin with,
it's all there,
which is really quite interesting,
but so they Z,
as they learn a particular language,
they zero in on the proper
way to pronounce that and
their minimized and every
time you learn something now that's how
it is and that's really useful to know
too because it means that it's okay to
wander around stupidly before you fix
your destination.
Now you see that echoed in exodus,
right?
Because what happens is that the Egyptians
or the Hebrews escape materiality,
which is kind of whatever you do
personally and psychologically,
when you escape from your previous
set of stupidly held and ignorant and
stubborn axioms,
it's like away from that tyranny.
It's like,
great.
I freed myself from that.
Well then what?
Well,
you think,
well now I'm on the way,
it's no,
you're not.
Now you're in the desert where
you wonder around stupidly,
you know and worship the wrong things
until you finally organized yourself
morally again and head
in the proper direction,
so that's worth knowing
too because you think,
well,
I got rid of a lot of things,
baggage,
excess baggage that I
didn't need in my life,
and now everything's okay.
It's like,
no,
it's not.
You've got rid of a whole set of scaffolds
that were keeping you in place even
though they were pathological.
Now you have nothing and nothing actually
turns out to be better than something
pathological,
but you're still stuck with
the problem of nothing,
and that's,
well,
that's exactly why exit this is
structured the way that it is.
It's that you escaped from maturity.
It's hooray.
We're no longer slaves.
Yeah,
well now you're nihilistic and lost.
It's not necessarily an improvement,
but it is,
but it is the pre.
See,
it's also useful to know that because you
can also be diluted into the idea that
imagine that you're trying
to become enlightened,
which might mean to turn all those
parts of you on that could be turned on.
You think,
well,
that's just a linear pathway uphill.
You know,
it's just from one success to another.
It's no,
it's not.
It's like here you are and you're not
doing too badly and the first step is a
complete bloody catastrophe.
It's worse and then maybe you can pull
yourself together and you hit a new
plateau and then that
crumbles and shakes and bang.
It's worse again and so because part
of the reason that people don't become
enlightened is because it's punctuated
by intermittent deserts essentially by
intermittent catastrophes,
and if you don't know that well then
you're basically screwed because you go
ahead on your movement forward
and you collapsed and you think,
well,
that didn't work.
I collapsed.
It's like,
no,
that's par for the course.
It's not indication that you failed.
It's just indication that it's really
hard and that when you learn something,
you also unlearn something and the thing
you unlearned is probably useful and
unlearning it actually is painful.
You know,
let's say if you have to get
out of a bad relationship,
it's like not every,
not any.
There isn't any relationship
that's a hundred percent bad.
So when you jump out of it,
well maybe you're in better shape,
but you're still lonesome and disoriented.
You don't know what your past was and
you don't know what your present isn't.
He don't know what your future is.
It's that's not.
That's why people stay with the
devil they know instead of you know,
looking for the devil they don't know so,
so anyways,
the fact that you're full
of faults doesn't mean you
have to stop and thank God
for that.
That's a really useful thing and the
fact that you're full of faults doesn't
mean that you can't learn and so you can
pause it in an ideal and you're going
to be wrong about it,
but it doesn't matter because what
you're right about is positing the ideal,
moving towards it.
If the actual ideal isn't
conceptualized perfectly,
well first surprise,
surprise,
because like what are you
going to do that's perfect.
So it doesn't matter that it's imperfect,
imperfect,
it just matters that you do
it and that you move forward.
So that's really,
that's really positive news as far as
I'm concerned because you could actually
do that,
right?
You can do it badly
and anyone can do that.
So that's,
that's useful.
Okay.
So like if you were an efficient person,
you would have just done
that but you're not.
But who cares,
you know,
and you still end up in the,
in the same place and maybe the
trip is even more interesting.
Who knows?
Probably too interesting.